that's how it's going to look in
cleveland
coming up late next month and
amazingly
they are planning for
an in-person draft
with a large amount of people
there will be indoor and outdoor
elements to it the indoor venue you must
be vaccinated if you are going to attend
all fans in that inner circle
must be must be vaccinated they will be
draft ambassadors selected by each team
uh open air you know the nfl continues
to
believe and really prove over and over
again that the open air transmission is
is difficult to accomplish now
it's it's still not the kind of
experiment you want to engage in on a
regular basis and cram a bunch of people
into a tight open air space but
you know the nfl is finding a way where
they can do it safely they can do it
responsibly they can do it effectively
and they can give the folks at home
something that feels yeah like a big
deal that's what it's all about yeah
putting it in a spot where when you
televise it it feels like a big deal and
there's a way to do it even with social
distancing and masks and in a
responsible way that feels like a big
deal and even though they pulled off the
stay-at-home draft last year
not exactly something that they want to
do on a regular basis it doesn't feel
like a big deal there's only so much you
can do and we've seen all we want to see
of stay-at-home activities this year on
tv this is great and and if they can
pull this off
then it underscores the confidence chris
that the league has that the stadiums
will be full yeah in 2021 because make
no mistake about it yeah you know the
league is concerned that in some states
the political realities will prevent a
full stadium right i think this draft at
some level
showing the world right that this can
work showing the nation this can work
showing california yeah and new york and
massachusetts this can work that helps
push it through
to get full stadium authorization when
september rolls around agreed right give
everybody a little confidence hey look
they're out there it's a crowd okay you
know yeah i'm with you first off i'm
excited as a fan as well done as that
zoom draft was last year by the nfl and
it was phenomenal for what the resources
they had available nothing beats the
draft the fanfare the excitement all 32
teams we're going to the super bowl
because we're gonna win the draft today
we're all going we're all going to the
super bowl i mean that's just there's
something about that time you know of
the year that it excites all nfl fans
and you know if there's one league in
our country that can pull this off and
do it the right way it is the nfl i mean
the nfl just
again
whether you go to sporting events or
anything nfl security is the tightest
security of any sporting event they're
going to be all over people wearing
masks and following the rules and doing
all those type of things they're not
want to be called out about that so um
you know we'll we'll see how it goes i
know they're going to do all the right
things take all the right precautions
and and the fact that the majority of it
is going to be outside by a lake where
there's wind blowing and things like
that i would think that that would be
one of the lesser chances
you have to you know
contract the virus
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports